Next, let's take a look at the user interface for the LiveLink V-CAM to better understand
some of the options available to us as we start to use this interface.
Now the interface will look different depending on whether you're using say an iPad or an
iPhone, but the core features will be all here.
So some of the elements we have available to us include the application log, kind of
your standard output log in Unreal to the device system stats, which will include things
like our aspect ratio and our bit rate and our time code.
We'll see the ability to disconnect from the session and go back into our standard Unreal
Engine editor.
We can see our camera stats, in this case 18 millimeters, and a 16 by 9 aspect ratio
also translated as 1.778.
Over here we can see our aperture stats including our ISO, which is set to auto, a focal distance
of 1000 meters, and an f-stop of 2.8.
The little camera icon over here will tab out to give us additional camera settings,
similarly with tools over on the right side.
And for 9 and 10, we have a virtual joystick system not unlike the default touch interface
that you'll see when developing a mobile game.
This is set up so that the left joystick will move us on the XY axis and the right
joystick will be for boom and pan.
We'll see this in action in the next lesson.
A few other elements to take note of, we have of course our viewfinder in the middle.
We have the ability to add bookmarks if we would like to snap easily to different camera
points in our bookmark manager.
We have our playback controls, which will look familiar to anyone who has used the sequencer
or cinematic viewport, although with the touch interface we can actually scrub our finger
along here to also move forward or backward in time.
15 is our record button, very much like the take recorder.
16 shows our axis scale, more about that on the next slide, and our stabilization stats.
We can tune this up or down depending on how much camera shake we want to have.
We have our tilt pan and roll degrees just to get a sense of the current rotation of
our camera.
And lastly over here we have the name of our slate and the sequence frame that we are currently
on.
More information as always can be found in the Unreal Engine documentation.
Here we see some of the additional options we're presented with when we open up our camera
toolbar as well as our tools toolbar.
Axis scaling is very similar to the world to meters scale setup for anyone who's worked
in virtual reality because this allows you to essentially change how your physical movement
will translate from the real world into this virtual world.
If you want to be able to cover a lot of ground very quickly by moving your iPad around and
using the AR features to cover more territory, you can dial up the axis scale to be able
to cover more ground, or if you would like more subtle movements, you can bring that
down.
You can also set the value to zero in order to lock and play with dialing these up or
down with your fingers on the left and right side.
So we have the axis scale on the left and the joystick movement gain, joystick rotation
gain over on the right.
Over here we see some of the dials that give us additional access to our camera controls.
So our lens control for a lens preset on the inner dial and the focal length on the outer
dial.
We have the right dial allowing us to adjust our f-stop as the inner dial and our focal
distance as the outer dial.
And then over here we have our film back control to select any presets we might have like
16 by 9 for example or other aspect ratios.
Continuing down here we have the ability to adjust our ISO and exposure control and then
we also have our f-stop out here.
On the right here we have our exposure compensation so we can dial the perceived brightness of
the world up and down.
Here allows us to adjust our near clip plane depending on how close we want to be able
to get to objects before they start to clip out of existence.
A couple more key features to draw your attention to include the reposition button which basically
allows you to lock the camera in one spot and then you can physically move in the real
world without changing that position.
This is great if you are restricted in your physical movement but actually want to cover
a larger space.
Same idea can be done with tilt.
For example if you want to have a very severe Dutch angle that might be harder to achieve
in the real world and you need to dial up that rotation depending on your physical movement
or just get yourself in a more comfortable physical position while having a potentially
more extreme angle.
Next up we'll look at filming a shot with the Vcam and then insert that shot into an
existing sequence.